Let's delve in a little bit to
the some of the things that
we've said in the last couple of slides.
So I brought back the options
that we had before and
the little pictures and I erased a bunch
of stuff and then I made a change.
Do you see the change?
>> You got rid of the word, yes, I was
going to say you got rid of the word
options but you actually changed
the word state into goal.
>> Well that wasn't what it
used to say in the title,
it didn't say state abstraction,
although I did write state
abstraction at some point.
>> It had temporal extraction.
>> That's right.
>> So what I want to point out,
you asked the question when before we
did the quiz, you said, well, wait,
are these things all
happening at the same time or
are they happening like,
how does this work?
Well, you touched on something kind of
neat there, right, which is We have
talked about so
far this kind of options things if well,
as if they're just primitive actions,
right?
You take one and
you take the other and take the other.
In other words we've
talked about sequencing.
And that's perfectly reasonable and
that's really what we've
been talking about and
everything that we've
talked about in this class.
But when you ask whether the things
could be running to the same time or
whether we're trying to
accomplish all these at once,
we're really talking about something
different, which is goals.
So I'm going to claim that although
we've been focusing on sequencing,
which makes sense, right?
We're talking about sequential
decision processes, right?
That's the whole point
of what we're doing.
You could think about these
things as running in parallel.
Although we talk about, well first
we're going to take the option of go to
the east door, and then I'm going to
execute the option go to the south door,
and then I'm going to go down,
down left or whatever I'm going to do.
You could conceptualize this as actually
all the options are running
at the same time.
So, I am always trying to go to the east
door, the south door, the other
south door, the other east door, and any
given time, one of them is in control.
I mean conceptually that's no different,
really, right?
>> So, maybe, I mean I guess it
sounds like what you're describing is
a little bit like a,
like a call stack in computer languages.
The idea that sure
while we're going after
that first goal of getting to
the east door in the north east room.
You know in the back of our mind just
the idea that we're; the reason we're
doing that is so
that we can do these other goals next.
>> No I actually mean something
a little bit different.
So, imagine I had a bunch of things
running in parallel, imagine we
had a thing called a computer right, and
the computer did many things at once.
So it was recording,
it was printing, it was
letting some program compile in the
background while the user was editing.
>From the computer's point of view,
right, the way we think about
these things is these things are all
sort of running at the same time.
But at least from with respect
to any individual processor,
only one thing can be
happening at the same time.
So we can write down everything as
if it's happening in sequence, but
in some sense it's happening in
parallel or they're all fighting for
resources at the same time.
But only one of them can be in
control at any given point in time.
So, even though the world is sequential,
we think about executing an option
then executing another option.
A kind of, it's a reason way of
thinking about the world but
there's another kind of conceit
one could take which is
all of these things want to run they
all want to happen at the same time.
They're constantly saying take me,
take me, take me.
I want to have control of the mouse,
or I want to control the screen or
whatever, and
we're just choosing which one to let go.
So they're still running at the same
time they're just not in control at
the same time in aren't
able to do anything.
Once you do that,
you end up thinking, or
you can end up thinking about of this
problem of temporal abstraction is not
one of sequencing things directly but
as one of managing competing goals.